welcome to Sunderland for our special
show brexit crisis
Deal or No Deal 12 leave voters 12
remain voters one city as brexit rumbles
on what do the people of Sunderland
think should happen next
the big issue to start how the economy
here could be affected given that 1
billion pounds has been invested here
from Europe in the last 5 years
does anyone really think in this room
but a Tory government is going to
replace that money into the north I mean
come on get real and we're going to be
we are going to be in chaos after this
we spend more than we own we consume
more than we produce we've got to make
more things here we can use tariffs to
do that I mean reactors the single
market hasn't worked for the UK and
there was very little sympathy for those
negotiating brexit this whole thing is a
big step in the unknown and it should
have been a cross-party negotiation not
just that the government the way it's
been handled the infighting is if you
stated there is it's alarming it really
is and we really are looking at 650
laymen who haven't got a clue on March
the 29th
it's a busy as the week of the year in
in my industry in the calendar and my
business could potentially stop them
that day if some decisions are not made
and then the deal we can't leave with no
deal or a bad deal I think in order to
improve where we're going now we
definitely need more cross party
negotiation that clearly isn't going on
we should go to the nor deal situation
which will you know there'll be some
bumps in the road but the advantage of
that is then suddenly once you cross
that line then people actually have to
then come back to the table Iguanodon
that's terrifying but we should stop
catastrophizing all the difficulties and
start relishing the possibilities we've
got a complete open field
all eyes are now on the Prime Minister
and what she'll do next to edge Britain
closer to that elusive deal Nick Martin
Sky News Sunday